I want to bring you some breaking news
from Niger we're getting reports that
the French Ambassador has left the
contract this departure follows a
military coup in July that overthrew
former president Muhammad bassum niger's
new rulers ended military cooperation
with France and ordered its Ambassador
and troops to leave
well we've got Nicholas hack who's
following the developments in Niger from
Dhaka first we're going to go to Natasha
Butler who's in the French Capital how
is France reacting to its Ambassador
being ordered to leave
yes well first I should say that we are
getting uh reports that the ministerial
and diplomatic sources here in France
have confirmed that the Ambassador has
left the Army that's being reported by
French news agency AFP because there had
been uh some confusion over that a
little bit earlier and and look for
France you might say it's not a surprise
the French President Emmanuel macron
earlier this week in a television
interview said that France would be
withdrawing its ambassadorite within the
coming days and also withdrawing its 1
500 troops from the country but all of
this of course is something of a blow a
climb down by Paris because for weeks we
have been hearing from the French
government from the French president
that it would not give in to the demands
of niger's military rulers that uh
French troops and the Ambassador leave
the country president macron himself
repeatedly saying that as far as Paris
was concerned the military rulers are
not the legitimate Authority in the
amine therefore Paris would not would
not give in to any of their requests or
demands but clearly this is not the case
we have the Ambassador on the way we
know that the withdrawal of troops could
take several weeks several months and
all of this uh just another difficult
chapter for uh France's policy in Africa
that has been so battered in recent
years with a number of coups in
countries that were once former colonies
Natasha Butler in Paris Natasha thank
you very much let's go to Nicholas
hackey's following developments from
Dakar in Senegal so the Ambassador has
gone the French troops as I understand
it and other foreign troops are still in
Nigeria what's the latest on them
foreign
this plane that took off from niamey was
long awaited there's been protests
outside the French ambassador's
residents asking for him to leave and so
the French didn't want us to have a
scene so he departed nieme at 3 45 a.m
in the morning away from public eye
there was no one allowed to film that
scene and then he went to in gemina
where there's a French military base and
then he's as we heard on his way to
Paris this is a small victory for the
military Junta led by General chiani who
has asked for the ambassador to leave
that doesn't mean that it's the end of
the Diplomatic relationship between
France and Niger there is still the
deputy in charge who will take over
Silva iche's role but the departure of
Silva iche was a key Demand by the
military Junta in Niger who had wanted
to see a reset of the relationship
between share in France on the
Diplomatic front on the military front
and on the economic front on the
military front there's 1 500 soldiers as
Natasha explained now they're due to
leave before the end of the year but
Nigeria's military Junta has again
reasserted that it it wants to be done
on its own timeline
and not the timeline of France then
there is the economic relationship Niger
is one of the biggest exporter of
uranium in the world and a French
company orano just in April discovered
the biggest Reserve untapped Reserve in
Niger in in the area of umararen and and
so the the Civil Society actors in Niger
are calling for a renegotiation of these
economic contracts that have been in pla
plays for the last 50 years since
Independence so there's a real uh urge
from both the Civil Society but also
Nigeria's military Junta to overall the
relationship both on the economic
military and diplomatic fronts with
France Nicholas thank you very much
indeed Nicholas hack talking to us from
Dhaka